all right what's the next category
ashley best trash taste special oh i
guess we did leave this one in i thought
we cut this one out but i guess we
didn't leave in the trash
but uh i guess they left it in there oh
god don't you look like a clown right
now huh
it's the new season now this counts as
the next year you can already be
nominated get the nominations
guys i guess uh there's only three
nominees
ones are they'll pick so we obviously
that our first one
was the chess tournament off yeah
chester mike which was uh
insane then we got the trash taste uh
real tokyo drifting
and then the cycling across japan
special i like
all of these for their own reasons yeah
i i think that
the best story is the chess 100 i think
the most fun
to film with the drifting yeah and then
i think the cycling one showcases our
chemistry i feel cycling we definitely
like perfected
like yeah we learned a lot from the
drifting special we do
and uh like i don't know if we've
already mentioned this but by far the
best
thing about this was having the
walkie-talkies because imagine how
boring this would have been if we didn't
have the walkie-talkies
um i feel like the the drifting one to
me was a proof of concept to be like
okay
trash taste is cool can we take this
outside and bring the same chemistry
yeah
i also think that the thumbnail is like
the best one
i made that thumbnail i love it it's so
good they're all great thumbnails
honestly yeah and they're all great
videos but uh yeah this
i mean this one you like we've already
said i i'm
i'm like surprised how much the stars
aligned for this one this one was a real
strong um
this one i mean i love all of them yeah
they're all great and there are a lot of
people who watch the trash taste podcast
don't watch the specials please do
please just consider watching we put
so much work into this and it's fully
backed by the patrons yeah
it's that really fully done like
honestly we try to get as close to like
tv quality honestly i think the biggest
thing is we try to get it as close to tv
quality
without having a tv crew behind us yeah
yeah just a couple cameramen that's all
you do not know the [ __ ] logistics
that went into filming this one
oh my god we had to bust out the
blueprints for that one ellie was lucky
that she didn't have to help with that
one yeah
she would have lost her mind really hell
on it yeah uh but i guess without
further ado
let's uh find out which there is only
one winner there is only one
and the best trash taste special of the
year goes to
yeah the cycling special yeah well i'm
not i'm not i'm not surprised well
yeah if i had to if i was a betting man
i would put cycling drifting chest would
be the order yeah is it cycling drifting
chess
it is cycling yeah what is the
percentage
cycling one with 60.1 percent wow
that's the biggest margin we've had of
anything yeah 60.1
i mean i i was like i was honestly
surprised because after the drifting
special i was like this is our magnum
opus
i don't think we can top this i don't
know man because it took us like what
15 drafts to get something that was good
like we had so many drafts that sucked
and i was like oh god is this video just
bad
yeah we [ __ ] because i knew when we
were filming i think
when we switch off the cameras i knew we
would film the banger yeah but then
like it what i didn't realize was how
much of the editing we would have to put
into it
to like convey the feeling that i felt
when i was filming
big big shout out to muna and once again
man like he [ __ ] brought this video
honestly um mvp of the specials
not us honestly we just we just show up
and we just do random [ __ ]
i wouldn't say that man there's a lot of
planning that we had to do it was
[ __ ] hell
our bikes were a monstrosity of cables
and batteries
all the cameramen that helped us out as
well the amount of times i had to
rewatch the cycling special to like
create a coherent narrative out of this
because
because it was just like so all of it
like the first draft was so all over the
place
and trying to like weave that into
something that you guys could follow
um was probably the biggest challenge
i've had all year